welcome back everyone this is part six
in our series on contextual
representation we're going to focus on
Roberta Roberta stands for robustly
optimized Bert approach you might recall
that I finished the Bert screencast by
listing out some key known limitations
of the Bert model and the top item on
that list was just an observation that
the Bert team originally did an
admirably detailed but still very
partial set of ablation studies and
optimization studies so that gave us
gave us some glimpses of how to best
optimize Bert models but it was hardly a
thorough exploration and that's where
the Roberta team is going to take over
and try to do a more thorough
exploration of this design space
I think this is a really interesting
development because at a kind of meta
level it points to a shift in
methodologies the Roberta team does do a
much Fuller exploration of the design
space but it's nowhere near the kind of
exhaustive exploration of hyper
parameters that we used to see
especially in the pre-deep learning era
and I think what we're seeing with
Roberta is that it is simply too
expensive in terms of money or compute
or time to be completely thorough and so
even Roberta is a kind of very heuristic
and partial exploration of the design
space but nonetheless I think it was
extremely instructive
for this slide I'm going to list out
kind of key differences between Bert and
Roberta and then we'll explore some of
the evidence in favor of these these
decisions uh just after that
first item on the list Bert used a
static masking approach and what that
means is that they copied their training
data some number of times and applied
different masks to each copy but then
that set of copies of the data set with
its masking was used repeatedly during
epochs of training and what that means
is that the same masking was seen
repeatedly by the model
you might have an intuition that will
get more and better diversity into this
training regime if we dynamically mask
examples which would just mean that as
we load individual batches we apply some
random Dynamic masking to those so that
subsequent batches containing the same
examples have different masking applied
to them
clearly that's going to introduce some
diversity into the training regime and
that could be useful
for Bert the inputs to the uh model were
two concatenated document segments and
that's actually crucial to their next
sentence prediction task whereas for
Roberta inputs are sentence sequences
that may even span document boundaries
obviously that's going to be disruptive
to the next sentence prediction
objective but correspondingly whereas
Bert had that NSP objective Roberta
simply dropped it on the grounds that it
was not earning its keep
for Bert the training batches contained
256 examples Roberta upped that to 2000
examples per batch a substantial
increase
Bert used a wordpiece tokenizer whereas
Roberta used a character level byte pair
encoding algorithm
Bert was trained on a lot of data Books
Corpus and English Wikipedia Roberta
leveled up on the amount of data by
training on Books Corpus Wikipedia CC
news open web text and stories and the
result of that is a substantial increase
in the amount of data that the model saw
Bert was trained for one million steps
whereas Roberta was trained for 500 000
steps
pause there you might think that means
Roberta was trained for less time but
remember the batch sizes are
substantially larger and so the net
effect of these two choices is that
Roberta was trained for a lot more
instances
and then finally for the Bert team there
was an intuition that it would be useful
for optimization to train on short
sequences first the Roberta team simply
dropped that and trained on full full
length sequences throughout the training
regime
I think those are the high level changes
between Bert and Roberta there are some
additional differences and I refer to
section 3.1 of the paper for the details
on those
let's dive into some of the evidence
that they used for these choices
beginning with that first shift from
static masking to Dynamic masking this
table summarizes their evidence for this
Choice they're using Squad multi-nli and
binary Stanford sentiment Tree Bank as
their kind of benchmarks to make this
decision and you can see that for Squad
and SST there's a pretty clear win
Dynamic masking is better for multi-nli
it looks like there was a small
regression but on average the results
look better for dynamic masking and I
will say that to kind of augment these
results there is a clear intuition that
Dynamic masking is going to be useful
and so even if it's not reflected in
these benchmarks we might still think
that it's a wise choice if we can afford
to train in that way
we talked briefly about how examples are
presented to these models I would say
the two competitors that Roberta
thoroughly evaluated were full sentences
and Doc sentences so doc sentences will
be where we limit training instances to
pairs of sentences that come from the
same document which you would think
would give us a clear intuition about
kind of something like discourse
coherence for those instances
we can also compare that against full
sentences in which we present examples
even though they might span document
boundaries and so we have less of a
guarantee of discourse coherence
although doc sentences comes out a
little bit ahead in this Benchmark that
they have set up across Squad multi-nli
sst2 and race they chose full sentences
on the grounds that there is more at
play here than just accuracy we should
also think about the efficiency of the
training regime and since full sentences
makes it much easier to create efficient
batches of examples they opted for that
instead and so that's also very welcome
to my mind because it's showing again
that there's more at stake in this new
era than just accuracy we should also
consider our resources
this table summarizes their evidence for
the larger batch sizes they're using
various metrics here perplexity which is
a kind of pseudo perplexity given that
Bert uses bi-directional context and
they're also benchmarking against
multi-nli and sst2 and what they find is
that clearly there's a win for having
this very large batch size at 2000
examples
and then finally just the raw amount of
data that these models are trained on is
interesting and also the amount of
training time that they get and so what
they found is that they got the best
results for Roberta by training for as
long as they could possibly afford to on
as much data as that they as they could
include so you can see the amount of
data going up to 160 gigabytes here
versus the largest Bert model at 13 a
substantial increase
the step size going all the way up to
500 000 whereas for bird it was a
million but remember overall there are
many more examples being presented as a
result of the batch size being so much
larger larger for the Roberta models
and so again kind of another familiar
lesson from the deep learning era more
is better in terms of data and training
time especially when our goal is to
create these pre-trained artifacts that
are useful for fine tuning
to round this out I thought I'd mention
that the Roberta team released two
models base and large which are kind of
directly comparable to the corresponding
Bert artifacts the base model has 12
layers dimensionality of 768 and a feed
forward layer of 3072 for a total of 125
million parameters which is more or less
the same as Burt base and then
correspondingly Burt large has all the
same basic settings as burp bass and
correspondingly essentially the same
number of parameters at 355 million
as I said at the start of this
screencast Roberta was thorough but even
that is only a very partial exploration
of the full design space suggested by
the burnt model for many more results I
highly recommend this paper a primer in
bertology from Rogers at all it's a
little bit of an old paper at this point
so lots has happened since it was
released but nonetheless it's very
thorough and contains lots of insights
about how best to set up these bird
style models for doing various things in
NLP so highly recommended as a companion
to this little screencast